i got into the ism man when i was
14 15 years old
you know young you know
i grew up around you your standard pimps
and drug dealers and prostitutes and
crackheads and
you know
your everyday model of [ __ ] up society
you know
all right sharp sharp uh where you from
where'd you grow up
i was born in detroit michigan i moved
to the west coast las vegas when i was
two
uh
never saw the midwest ever again after
that
uh
grew up in las vegas a bit went to
school
you know typical american [ __ ] up
dream
you know same [ __ ] different day you
know average [ __ ]
uh
then i started uh start going to san
diego man real heavy when i was about 12
13 with a lot of my friends man we
always go you know
family members and whatnot a lot of
friends and you know [ __ ] like that
you know has always been my thing you
know how was your family huh how was
your family how was my family yeah both
your parents no man
i think that's what uh
i think that's you know that's what
really go on in today's world man is you
know you don't always have both your
parents you know and you can't really
blame them you know for not being there
so you know i just i just keep it moving
in my life man you know i never really
had my my mom was there she met a
boyfriend she ran out she was gone
when had another baby and you know
that was all they ever wrote for that
white horse
when did you first start working as a
pimp
said it again
when when did you start working as a
pimp
i got into the ism man when i was
14 15 years old
you know young you know
i grew up around you your standard pimps
and drug dealers and prostitutes and
crackheads and
you know
your everyday model of [ __ ] up society
you know
so
i always wanted something different man
you know i i was a kid every every kid
had a dream you know
want to be a baseball player
football player or
doctor
you know always want to be some [ __ ]
like that who hasn't may want to grow
and be anything you want to be
well you know by the time i hit probably
about 12 or 13 i started noticing man
that that dream was gonna fade real
quick because of my surroundings you
know not having certain opportunities
you know what i'm saying like you know
other kids might have been as you know
fortunate
you know uh
but i still wanted the money man i still
wanted i still felt rich
you know
even though i'm living in a [ __ ] up
environment i'm living around [ __ ] that
you know hey nobody's really that
fortunate man we're all in the same boat
trying to get out you know a bunch of
crabs in the bucket trying to crawl out
man and get out you know
and i always felt different than
everybody else man
you know i did different things i moved
different you know i didn't want to do
what everybody else was doing you know i
kind of stayed to myself you know all i
mess with a lot of broads when i was
coming up you know i always had a bunch
of females you know as friends as a kid
you know young you know from first grade
on up i've been having girlfriends i was
never scared of girls i was never a boy
like that to where i you know get away
from me no man none of that
you know i've always loved them and [ __ ]
they love me do you have sisters
did you have sis i had a couple but i
don't know okay
i mean did you feel you were destined
for for something greater than everyone
else around you yeah yeah and that's why
i think you know i picked up what i
picked up [ __ ] man the game found me
you know
i didn't find the game the game found me
man it's not for everybody
you know and there's definitely no gray
areas
like this skid row is a bunch of them
you know it's not it's not none of that
man
how did it begin for you how did it
start your first girl
i was a kid man i was young [ __ ] my
first girl man [ __ ] she's 26 years old
14 15 years old man
for real turned me on showed me the way
you ain't got to be broke no mo
you ain't got to hurt no more
you know already coming from hurtful
environments you know and i always had a
older mentality i grew up fast i grew up
around you know older people like all my
friends when i was young were already
well in their 30s
i'm saying headed to their head into
into their 30s
well into their 40s you know that's why
now me being in my 30s and all my
friends is 50s and 60s you know i don't
really have too many young friends you
know few but
not a lot
you know that's how i came into it man
was you had to grow up fast you had to
move fast i didn't choose that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] chose me
you know
didn't ask for none of it man
it's just life
life has a calling for everybody
it's mine i guess yeah
and the pimping game has changed the
style used to be flashier and little
more guys had more style
yeah man you seem to be cut from that
clock yeah man i come from listen i come
from the old school game with the is a
man when you had to put a capital p on
it man
you dig you had to put a capital p on it
now man let me tell you something man
you you got people out today
that
want to do it for a weekend want to be
in the streets or in a life in a
lifestyle any type of lifestyle may want
to do it for a weekend but they want to
go back on monday acting like everything
has changed it doesn't it's not like
that for everybody
everybody some people still got to keep
the lights on the same way they turned
them on
you know yeah
[ __ ] a lot of attempts i've
interviewed that uh
seem to be
they seem to be like just drugs drug
dealers imposters man yeah imposters
i've seen some of that and never seen
these guys in my entire [ __ ] life
none of them except for maybe one or two
and that's just of knowing so you're out
of las vegas huh san diego city yeah but
i live in las vegas you live in vegas
yeah i've been listening man las vegas
and san diego are both my own i'm a
sandy vegan
because i go back and finish my homes
man it's always been my homes i can't
really claim san diego too much i can't
really claim las vegas too much they're
both my homes
can't help how i grew up or where i grew
up man i was everywhere the whole west
coast was my home
you know i don't really i can't really
say hey i was born and raised here [ __ ]
i was took it out of the place i was
born at that too
so i can't really cloud on i got robbed
of that title
can't really say that like you know i
can't say oh man i was born and raised
right here man right now man i was
raised everywhere i was everywhere maybe
that's why i'm everywhere today
how many girls do you have in your
stable
i want to talk about that
you ever been arrested
yeah
i had a
couple of money laundering charges
back in 2014
you know i did i
did what i needed to do to get away from
it you know
i don't have any more problems it's all
behind me
you know i wouldn't even be here today
if it wasn't
i wouldn't even want to tell my side of
the story of nothing if it wasn't
what's it what's the arrangement you
have with the girls you you handle what
part of the money
my arrangements is my arrangements uh
you know what i'm saying i take care of
my business they take care of business
we all take care of business
it's a happy life
last time i checked
give kids a euro i got kids and you
raise them got kids yeah
do the best that i can are you married
no no no
married to the gang
[Laughter]
what are the qualities you think of pimp
needs to be successful
ambition
you know uh
stride you gotta you you
you have to understand that man it's all
about progress it's all about making
progress not to prove to the next man
this not to prove to the next woman that
nah man to prove to yourself
because it's only you man it's a one-man
sport there is no team
[ __ ] run around and money
clicks and
all this extra [ __ ] look at me and look
at us that's not the game
it's not the game
you don't have to have the strongest
muscles in the world and you ain't got
to run around with 100 guns you know
what you got to have man this
right here man your mind
your body and your soul jack
and i've lived that man all my life
you know most people man you know sell
drugs and
you know uh
did a lot of gang banging or
you know had people like that that was
around them you know i always wanted to
be the the money getting guys
i always seen the man the flashy cars
the
houses man you know beautiful women all
the diamonds the women looking beautiful
man that's cold jack that's the game
that's the way it's supposed to be man
not this gorilla and let's end up on
your five o'clock tv
what are the qualities you look for in a
female
all she got to do man is have a good
mind like myself
i don't look for nobody i don't look for
anybody broken
or need fixing no man that's not the
life man you got you have to understand
you got
college coaches
daughters doing it all by themselves
i'm not around i don't know any i'm just
what i know what you see man it's a it's
an everyday
it's an everyday life man people pick it
up man it's a it's a way of life
you know it's a way of life man
not the way they try to portray it on tv
you know crackheads and a bunch of
people running around that don't got no
business being outside no man that's the
way they portray it to you on tv
it's not the way of life man that's not
the way that it goes and it's sad man
because it's killing the game with these
suckers running around thinking that
they could be a part of something that
was never for them listen to me i don't
come in your kitchen telling you how to
make a sandwich i just eat the [ __ ] when
you make it
church
do you think women are
looking for a replacement of their
father figure when they're
when they have a relationship with a
with the pimp
no
i think that they're all we i think all
of us are just searching for love that
we ain't never had before
and i don't think it's anything to do
with your mother or your father that's a
different kind of love man that's a
different kind of love you know that's
sick that's twisted people try to throw
that [ __ ] in there you know oh you got
daddy issues that's that's sick
it's [ __ ] sick
you know what i'm saying
it's that's that's not the name of the
game man
you know we all looking for something
that we ain't never had before
that's all that is man something we've
never had something i've never had [ __ ]
something that you probably still
searching for
we're just trying to beat everybody to
it man that's it
we actually got smart there's actually
people out there man that actually
understand
you know
look how we get look how the ism gets
portrayed anymore man
look at it
boyfriend and girlfriend gfe
bfe let's lay up hey i'll kill you if
you you talk to my [ __ ] man [ __ ] out of
here man
go get married you want to be a square
go get a square job
if you hadn't become what other careers
do you think you may have
if you hadn't become a pimp what other
careers you think you may have
excelled at
i would have excelled at a lot of things
but you know i don't want to think about
that i like to think about the things
that i did excel at you know the things
that i'm great at because
shoulda coulda woulda the past is the
past what i could have been in the past
what i could it's not about that it's
about what i am right here right now
live and in the making
you know that real [ __ ]
that tasty [ __ ]
yeah sons are daughters
you know i got a couple of daughters
god you'll say unfortunately i'm saying
god you know unfortunately he gave me a
couple of daughters that i'm gonna have
to deal with you know but
i love a man and you know what
i wouldn't change it for the world it's
a piece of my life man
you know i had him in the game you know
i didn't
go and stop or do this and do that and
all i had them in the game and you know
i try to be there for them as much as i
can they come with me i take care of a
man we live just as normal as
your
your average joe next doe
you know
what what would you say if one of your
girls one day
decides she wants to uh
to work as a prostitute
say that again if one of your daughters
one day decides she wants to work as a
prostitute
i'll tell you right now man do i want my
daughter being a prostitute no i don't
want my daughter being a prostitute i
don't think any man wants their daughter
being a prostitute but you know what
this is life
i can't
stop that all i can do is just try to
embed into her as much as i can that hey
baby this the path that you're taking
your life
you know but if she goes and that's what
she does man she grown what can i say
what can i do man this is life
this is life we live in man i can't
control it you can't control it can you
control life and what's happening
outside this doe right now because i
know i damn sure can this shit's rough
let's look at what's going on i want to
go out here let's talk to everybody
right now take the camera and tell them
hey man come on man let me do hey
hey i'm running this no
because everybody's got their own lives
man they own paths man i can't stop that
my daughter being a prostitute do i want
her to be one [ __ ] no
but
if that's what she's gonna be i'm gonna
respect it i'm at least gamer [ __ ] go
get with something real
don't play yourself short
there's too many people that's outside
right now outside this door that's
playing themselves short right now
right now it's thousands of them
thousands of them we can go talk to
right now hey man when you start playing
yourself short oh it was a summer
when they were four years old you know
when you start playing yourself man you
got it from their from their from their
parents
but i
i love the game man i love from what it
used to be i kind of got stuck in that
you know
probably a time in your life that you
got stuck in and you didn't want to
leave
well i got stuck in the purities and the
realness of the ism
no nothing else true
i wish i could tell you that i did
i mean i'm a smart guy
book smart you know i made sure i tried
to do that somewhat you know throughout
my life
if you ask me what i've been great at
you're looking at all of it
all right sharp thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you appreciate
it sure thanks man yeah